make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so picking up with deceased number
two this story is do this story is so
good
here's the thing about Tom Taylor
writing man Tom Taylor writing is legit
like it's one okay Tom Taylor's really
really good at writing like dark stories
right it's just like things are popping
off and people are dying get Tom Taylor
to write it like Tom Taylor's really
good at that I would not give like
Captain America to Tom to him although
it probably would be a pretty cool story
be dark but it'd be probably a pretty
cool stir okay so many more upbeat
somebody more light heart right like I
would not give a spider-man story to Tom
Taylor there we go like I wouldn't I
wouldn't give spider-man a Tom Taylor um
because he would ride a pretty dark
spider-man story uh but the world's
ending because like cyborg released a
virus onto the world like blood was a
carrier for the ante life equation which
spread through technology yeah man let's
hunt hillier write that story and it
turns out exactly the way you would
expect because again from the first
video that we saw that's basically
what's happening right like Darkseid
who'd essentially found the anti-life
equation and the dark side was corrupted
by this sort of twisted version of the
anti-life equation that he that he
essentially created and then in turn
with cyborg being a carrier for it cyber
war was kind of teleported back to earth
when like Darkseid became corrupted went
crazy and everything and then cyborg
released it into the internet right like
release it over the digital space which
basically is kind of like this digital
virus right so for those you guys who
saw who who ever read a cellular I think
was called cellular by uh by Stephen
King that's basically it right like a
virus that spreads throughout the world
using digital information and it works
exceedingly well and that's one of the
things I like about this right like if
this was a direct copy of Marvel Zombies
well then something something something
something now we have zombies people are
being bitten and they're turning into
zombies right but like that's been done
before what better way to create a kind
of zombies story more or less then to
like have it spread through the internet
like we saw in Final Crisis it's a great
way to do it it's a really cool concept
and so in this one we basically pick up
in the middle of the Atlantic Ocean with
Aquaman and all the Mansour's kinda like
okay she's like there's a boat out here
in the middle of nowhere and like cargos
dumping everywhere and like these are
popping off what in the world happening
and like when he opens this this door of
the ship in the hole there's like
monsters everywhere and Aquaman just
flees for his life this is kind of cool
because what this does is it begs the
question can Atlantis be affected right
because like what you're talking and
we'll talk more about this here once we
get towards the end of the video because
Tom Taylor kind of indirectly answers
that question uh but with Atlantis being
so far below the surface
and in a lot of ways being in a place
where you kind of have to wear like a
pressurized suit otherwise this shear
pressure would probably crush you it's a
question of like can people make it down
there with no protection whatsoever in
order to successfully infiltrate the
place but at this point we kind of jump
over to Metropolis right and so you got
Jonathan Kent
you've got Damian Wayne you've got Lois
Lane and you've got Superman now again
they're kind of picking up in the middle
of all this and that's the nature of
this whole thing remember it spreads so
far so fast like it was like Skynet
going live in the blink of an eye this
virus was all over the world and just
like everything's kind of falling all at
the same time but it also restricts
their ability to be able to access it to
be able to speak to different people
right like Lois Lane's response is we
have to go to the Daily Planet but our
our first inclination is that won't do
you any good because it's being spread
to the digital space so anybody who
picks up like a cellular phone or
anything that's connected to the
Internet like a smartphone or something
like that they're gonna be infected by
this anti-life equation so so you need
something like a rotary phone right like
you need something that's like old hat
technology analog information so it's
kind of a cool little thing because
presumably the Daily Planet has that now
the other half of this is of course
Damian Wayne's freaking out of her
Batman that's one thing I want you guys
to notice is this story of course takes
place in it doesn't take place in the
main DC continuity but it does include
the characters as they exist right now
right like Damian Wayne's a little bit
older Jonathan Kent is of course older
there's a couple steps that we can take
to sort of make this fit in the sense of
like we can kind of assume that things
haven't progressed the exact same way
right like Jonathan was not taken by his
grandfather into space and then aged up
we can assume a lot of those things
didn't happen so like Bendis you know
this the bit misses version of Superman
doesn't take place in this universe and
said they just kind of aged up
accordingly right there is some number
of years older than they normally are
and we can just kind of call it a day
right like we need to sort of take those
those lenience 'iz and and and be done
with it but I'm switching over to Harley
Quinn this is an important thing because
what this shows is not everyone's aware
of what's going on and and for the most
part even those who are aware what's
going on don't really seem to have the
full understanding of what's happening
right like picking up with Harley Quinn
and poison ivy there's no indication
here that like zombies are infecting
everything or anything like that they're
just kind of having a general
conversation poison ivy is like hey you
got to go in there and you got to do
your thing when you come out I'll be
waiting for you in the Botanic Gardens
everything's gonna be okay
Harley Quinn has no real idea what's
going on and neither seemingly this
poison ivy and so when Harley Quinn
walks into this room we of course
realize she's talking to the Joker she's
like hey I came here to tell you I'm
running off with poison ivy I'm leaving
here
and I'm never coming back our life
together is over and it's at that point
that we find out that Joker has
basically been turned into one of these
zombies now here's the cool question to
be asked here here's here's the cool
question that we need to ask you if the
Joker is one of these zombie monsters is
there any real difference like that's
the cool question to ask and I guess it
depends on which version the Joker
you're talking about right like if
you're talking about Steve Englehart
Joker right like the version that Batman
the Animated Series was based off of
then yeah you probably see a pretty big
difference but if we're talking about
like Scott Snyder new 52 death and the
family Joker
light or death of the family Joker like
honestly I don't know if you'd see that
huge of a difference you would just see
more crazy than usual now here's the
thing I want to see I want to see zombie
Joker versus the Batman who lost that's
what I want to see let me tell you
something dude I would I would pay I'd
pay however much money DC's charging to
read that one shot all did a baby like
it's a hundred dollars to read this and
I would be like here you go like take my
money I wouldn't even care it would be
it'd be amazing to see but in this
moment Joker's basically infected by
this virus more or less and is
presumably gonna tear apart Harley Quinn
and so from here we actually shift over
what to what I think is one of the
coolest moments in the entire the entire
story when we pick up outside of
Metropolis now again this is kind of an
important thing to bear in mind here
unless you're in a major city you for
the most part don't really know what's
going on and that makes the most sense
right I mean those individuals who were
in like major metropolitan areas are
usually tapped in more in the digital
space but those were in like outlying
rural territories right I mean as a guy
who lived in Kentucky Lexington and
Louisville are the two biggest cities
and so everything outside of that you
got rich man you got Winchester
Versailles Harrodsburg and then you go
out further and you run into places like
Rockcastle County and things like that
and the further out you go and even the
closer you go east to the Appalachian
Mountains the less technologically
advanced people become and so when you
when you're in that kind of an
environment when you're further out and
you're not tapped into the digital space
at the time that this goes down you have
no idea what's going on because you're
so far removed from the environment
around you now you would kind of expect
that like the various explosions that
we're hearing and/or seeing and things
like that at metropolis at the very
least that noise would reach the ear of
like Black Canary and Anna and Oliver
Queen Green Arrow and Hal Jordan you
would expect that it would reach them
but for whatever reason it hasn't maybe
that is so far outside of Metropolis but
they're not really picking up on it but
the cool thing is were kind of going
back and forth and having their own
little banter and it's actually kind of
a cool tip on the nod and the reason why
is because if you're not really familiar
with the history of Green Lantern Green
Arrow
it doesn't really resonate with you
but for those people who do there's a
lot of not really callbacks but just
kind of a great little bit of nostalgia
here right because like Green Lantern
and green arrow those two guys were
brought together because their comics
weren't really selling and so DC merged
them together and basically put them in
a singular story it was essentially a
team-up book for like a number of years
and here's a funny thing is it was
actually incredibly popular like it was
it was insanely popular you wouldn't
expect it to be but it was oh it was
hugely popular and people loved it
because of the dynamic while you had the
joking nature of Oliver Queen combined
with the more serious tone of Hal Jordan
and you got some great stories by Neal
Adams and Dennis O'Neil right like snow
birds don't fly different things like
that fun again these guys have been
exceedingly good friends for a very very
long time and so that's why it's kind of
cool to see them paired together so for
people who are fans of Green Arrow and
and Green Lantern they kind of look at
this and they say hey this is a cool
little throwback a cool little tip with
a nod to the to the old stories from
yesteryear but of course you know
they're also kind of giving Hal Jordan a
hard time because he's so serious all
the time so like you're like the killjoy
right like like Oliver Queen jumps up
and he was like he's like Hal Jordan you
have the ability to suck the fun out of
every situation
welcome to the killjoy Court which in
all honesty I kind of want to see that
right like just a bunch of cynical jerks
just going around and just being like I
don't enjoy anything and nothing's fun
or happy and I just complain about
everything all the time so basically
like a huge portion of Twitter right
like the killjoy court so it's like I
think it'd be funny like I think it'd be
kind of interesting right just like like
this this little mini series we're just
a bunch of like okay that's what you do
you just like basically make it like
people on Twitter right people who are
just like you know I just want to be
upset about something so I'm just going
to tweet about things that I'm angry
about and hope that somebody listens and
hope that I can fix my life even though
I can't not by tweeting on Twitter but
like I want to see like that that
miniseries just focuses on them right
like just some keyboard warrior at home
trying to change the world from a lounge
chair I really want to see it I really
want to see that story I think it would
be hilarious but nonetheless uh you know
what's Hal Jordan actually like goes
into his tent that's when everything
begins to go crazy right because it is
just like okay
so he gets on his phone and of course
she's immediately hit with the virus and
then starts losing his mind and then
like busts out so what we've got is
basically like this zombified Hal Jordan
as a Green Lantern wielding the power of
a Green Lantern a zombie Green Lantern
it's the coolest thing ever in a lot of
ways he almost reminds me of like a
combination of the Sinestro Corps and
the red lanterns right because like the
ring immediately says like lethal force
is a lethal force is not is not
sanctioned right so like
you cannot kill people now here's a
funny thing is it almost kind of seems
like Sinestro Corps war never happened
right because Sinestro Corps war is when
things change and the Green Lantern's
could start killing people so presumably
like Sinestro doesn't exist or the
Sinestro Corps war never took place
whatever the case says Green Lantern's
can't kill folks and so it's kind of
crazy because like he's trying to kill
them now here's where the big saving
grace comes in because then you've got
like Oliver Queen who's basically
attacked by Hal Jordan Cal Jordan goes
to kill him and then Dinah Lance the
black canary just like screams in the
face of Hal Jordan and just like
destroys his eardrums and it's a crazy
thing because like it basically like you
know scrambles his brains and it kills
him and then it's Hal Jordan Green
Lantern of sector to eight one four
deceased scanning for replacement
replacement found Dinah Lance of Earth
you have the ability to overcome great
fear
welcome to the Green Lantern's and it's
just like wow like it's the coolest
thing never in my life did I think it
would be cool to see Black Canary become
a Green Lantern but I'm excited about
that because imagine what she can do
with hardlight constructs and a sonic
scream I'm really excited by it right I
mean you can tell there's obvious
influence from injustice in this story
right like taking someone set of powers
and throwing it onto somebody else that
you at least expect and then just kind
of see how things play out there's
obviously a lot of injustice going on in
terms of how the story is being written
but it's it's it's really really awesome
now of course once you end up having
Superman and in company Superman Damian
Jonathan and Lois showing up at the
Daily Planet it's exactly what we would
expect right you know Superman's like
hey stay here this place is filled with
monsters so basically you know from from
what the house it may responds to Lois
this question is that people we know
Superman of course looks at and says yes
so we can assume Perry White we can
assume Jimmy Olsen we can assume a lot
of the people who have traditionally
been the supporting cast of the Superman
comics are essentially infected and and
they're they're you know they're caught
up by this virus and so with us this
cool thing happening Superman of course
does the one thing you're never supposed
to do I'll be right back which usually
never happens that's never usually the
case but of course the reason why he
takes off is not to go into the Daily
Planet it's because he heard a scream
and that's when he races over any ends
up realizing that like hey like Black
Canary is the Green Lantern we need you
to have these powers like we need you
with us you have to come along here and
so with that in mind like with of course
Black Canary in tow bringing Oliver
Queen they all basically show up here at
you know they come reach her into the
Daily Planet and that's when Batman
chimes in and it's like okay so Batman
basically says hey look they're not
really zombies in the traditional sense
they don't desire to consume flesh
basically the ante life right like these
are individuals who have been infected
with the anti-life equation all they
want to do is spread this anti life
right so it's kind of saying they're
dead but they're not dead it's
interesting because what Tom's Hill it
really kind of seems to indicate here
there may be a way to bring them back
but what Batman what he really does is
kind of clear that up right off the bat
when Batman says you can't cure them
there's no way to bring them back those
individuals that we lost are now gone
whatever percentage of the world's
population is infected is now infected
forever and so if you're not tapped into
a phone and you're bitten by one of
these guys you are now infected with
anti your life and the only way to
basically deal with you is to kill you
so in a sense they are basically zombies
just by a different name Reilly the only
thing they lack is just consuming flesh
they're zombies under a different
circumstance but again this is actually
a pretty sad moment because you've got
of course got Alfred standing by with a
shotgun and you've got Batman in the
suit of Mr Freeze basically cooling his
body down slowing his metabolism and
keeping the virus from like over running
him but he basically says like there's
no cure for there's nothing I can do
here like I am going to die like I'm
going to become one of those things
there's no way for me to kind of go back
to who I was and there's almost like
some doubt here right I mean Oliver
Queen she's like no no you're Batman
do you like Oliver Queen is like the
voice of the fan right he's like no
you're Batman dude you have prep time or
you know some fill in the blank reason
but like you always come back from this
and it's kind of cool because Batman
doesn't have prep time because Batman is
not prepared for it which of course
always answers the question what happens
when Batman doesn't have prep time he
dies so it's kind of a cool little thing
here like it's kind of a cool little
moment of like Batman be like like the
world like everybody's saying goodbye to
Batman saying like you know there's no
way we can bring you back and then this
is this was a really touching moment
because Batman didn't starts talking to
Damian and he's like hey look like
Alfred has something for you is
something I always left for you I knew
you would earn it notice this is
something Batman doesn't say Batman
doesn't say I love you son like he
doesn't he doesn't say you know I I love
you you know you're my son you know I'm
a he'd you of course resident somebody
doesn't really say like I love you and
and I always will or something along
those lines you don't really see that
kind of tender moment right you just
kind of see Batman being Batman where
it's like I left something for you you
would have earned it one day anyway you
would have taken this up which of course
we know that it's basically the bat suit
that Damian Wayne is going to become
Batman and so it's kind of a crazy theme
because of course at that point in time
- when Bruce begins to switch Riley
that's what he starts to turn into this
zombified version and it's the craziest
thing because Alfred does the only thing
he can do he says cease transmission it
never should have interviewed this way
I'm sorry son and then there's a shotgun
fire with that being said guys we're
gonna
this video to an end if you are new here
to comment explain make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the rod fork if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later purse
[Music]